welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is John McKay professor of Slavic
languages and literature's and film and
Media Studies his research interests
include 19th and 20th century Russian
literature Russian and Soviet culture
comparative literature literary and
cultural theory and film studies
especially film theory and documentary
cinema professor McKay's recent
publications include true songs of
freedom Uncle Tom's Cabin in Russian
culture and society for Russian serf
narratives and inscription and modernity
from Wordsworth to Mandal stem today we
talk with professor McKay about his
forthcoming book Dziga Vertov life and
work welcome professor McKay thanks for
having me Marilyn let's get right to the
book tell us about it
well this is a book that's a critical
biography of the filmmakers eGov Arthur
who lived between 1896 and 1954 he was
born in what is now Poland the eastern
part of Poland and then worked his
entire career after the Russian
Revolution in the Soviet Union
so he's one of the most important
figures in the history of Soviet film
and what the study does is look at both
his his upbringing actually his his life
during the war years and then his entire
filmmaking career up until the late
1930s at which point the book changes a
bit and it becomes about his last 20
years which were essentially a period of
dormancy he wasn't allowed to work
effectively right so it's a long period
of decline actually in the last section
of the book but prior to that there was
this very fertile moment of filming and
we'll get back to all that in a minute
but I am very curious
to know what led you to write this book
well I was introduced actually to Dziga
Vertov
by Charlie muster who teaches here in
film and Media Studies when I was a TA
for his intro to film class which I
actually teach now I teach that class
and that was the first time that I saw
Zig of ER thoth's the most famous film
man with a movie camera which is shown
in a lot of introductory film classes
and that film interested me a lot
because it brought together several
different interests I have it's a
documentary film a self-proclaimed
nonfiction film it's an experimental or
avant-garde film and it's also a Soviet
film a film that was made at a very
important point in Soviet history so it
brought together a lot of interest and
then when I started to teach when I got
hired here I found that there was almost
nothing written on him that was really
grounded in archival research okay and
so I went over to Russia and found that
there was in fact a gigantic archive and
started to build up some work so really
it was teaching that was my initial
prompts to work on von goethe okay in
terms of your methodology you mentioned
that a lot of the work was archival work
in Russia so did you do anything else
outside of that well yeah I mean there's
some there I worked in both paper and
film archives film archives in Sweden in
the United States I went to various film
festivals where certain films were shown
but then there's an awful lot of extra
research about the time about the
history as you may know since about 1991
or so after the end of the Soviet Union
there's been a real revolution in the
history in the historical writing about
the Soviet Union because the archives
opened up and so a lot of our I mean our
many of our conceptions especially about
sort of detailed things have changed
over the course of that time so I wanted
to great well we simply know more about
how people lived on the ground okay
there's a there are a lot of questions
we that have still have not been
answered
for sure but we do know more about the
way that institution kinds of
institutions worked
we certainly also know more about some
of the more catastrophic aspects of
course of Soviet history particularly
those that happened in the 1930s and the
war period as well which all of which he
lived through and even to some extent
documented so those are those are just
some of the big innovations that have
had let's talk a little bit about his
life tell us about who he was
well Zika vrf is a pseudonym actually
nobody is called Zika vieira Tov in
Russia it's just it's a Zika is a is a
nickname that he got it's hard to say
where it came from Zika is the word in
Ukrainian for a top a spinning like a
toy top right and via Tov is actually a
pseudonym that he came up with it comes
from the word to spin with a Russian
word to spin and it relates to our words
like invert or revert and so on it's got
the same kind of root and his real name
was David Kaufman okay and he was he was
from a Jewish family in Bialystok
Bialystok was at that point in the
Russian Empire probably the most Jewish
city in terms of just population in the
Russian Empire his dad was a bookseller
who had a great big bookstore that also
had a reading room that was quite
important in the city and he had two
brothers both of whom and crazily enough
became filmmakers as well one of them
Mikhail Kaufman his the next oldest
brother worked with the Arthur in the
1920s and had a distinguished career in
the Soviet Union his youngest brother
about East Kaufmann whose archive we
have here at the at the binary library
went to France and he shot all the films
of Jean Vigo one of the most famous of
all French filmmakers you perhaps have
heard of on the waterfront
he shot and won the Academy Award for
some photography for that film he shot
the only film that Samuel Beckett was
involved with actually a film simply
called film with buster
he shot film he shot films for a Sidney
Lumet like the pawnbroker for instance
so he had a very very distinguished
career both in France and in the United
States so it's a very intriguing
cinematic family as well right that they
seemed to have developed well the two
oldest developed together but the
youngest but he really just seemed to in
a sense he knew that his brothers were
working but he developed really quite
independently now how did they how did
they get involved in filmmaking well
that's an interesting story because
actually the artists when they when
growing up in Bialystok there was Vieira
Thoth had a good friend a guy whose name
was Friedland Michel Friedland who later
became he changed his name to and he
became Mikhail Koltsov who was the most
famous of all early Soviet journalists
he's like the Edward r murrow of the
early Soviet Union this is also from
this place okay he got the artifact AAB
in the fledgling Soviet film industry in
the nonfiction part of it they were
making newsreels and other kinds of
nonfiction films in 1918 okay so he
needed a job he hadn't had any prior
professional filmmaking experience he
might have been involved with making
scientific films at the Institute he
studied in in Petrograd during the first
world war which was called the psycho
neurological institute and so he it
seems as though that's quite likely that
he did and so he had there was a kind of
interest in film certainly there was a
deep deep interest in art and especially
in poetry and music okay but in a way he
just got thrown into this by chance Wow
okay so let's talk about his filmmaking
you mentioned one of the movies that
actually you're going to be showing here
at Yale of the man behind the camera man
was a movie camera yeah let's talk a
little bit about that and would you call
it his most his masterpiece for lack of
a more apt word well most people would
say that actually I mean that it is
certainly it's the best
known of his films although it's
actually only now been restored in tin
it's more or less original form for many
many years the film was only available
in what was cutting a basically a ound
film aperture that is to say a slight
amount of the image was taken off one
side in order to leave room for a
soundtrack which mangled the image
actually so there was one print of the
film that was left by the artists in the
Netherlands that was that was what we
call silent film aperture and so and
that makes a difference when you're
talking about photography that's that
carefully composed okay so yeah his
films the basic thing that people sort
of know about the Arthur is that he was
militantly in favor of nonfiction film
and militantly against fiction film and
why is that and the reason was I mean
there's a number of reasons why that is
the case but certainly from the point of
view of let's say politics he believed
that two fiction film essentially if it
were to be sort of restored within the
Soviet context and again they wanted to
create a new society in the Soviet Union
this would amount to simply dragging in
all these old stereotypes about people
men women specific characters peasants
workers or like different character
types plot cliches and so forth and this
was just unnecessary because the camera
doesn't need any of that the width and
cinematography and cinema in general
doesn't need any of that you can use the
camera to explore the world and create
different kinds of arrangements of image
and sound that don't depend in any way
on all those old pre-revolutionary
narrative character stereotypes so what
would he be filming well in the case of
men with the movie camera what he films
is it's actually difficult to limit what
he says one of the main thing that he
films is he films the cameraman filming
okay and is it more or less an
autobiography of him or or no it's
interesting I mean there is a way in
which it does have a certain it's
certainly a reflection on the kind of
work that he did he does appear in the
film at one point in the film but what
it what it is
is a film that is its first of all the
film is extremely complex ly edited and
one of the things that he seemed to want
to do was to show that nonfiction film
contrary to what might be thought can be
infinitely more creative more dynamic
more interesting more loaded than
fiction film and that's the opposite of
even what today people think I think oh
I'm gonna watch a documentary film right
I mean it's gonna be more boring and
this than that right it's just a cliche
right and that was the cliche even back
then we're just gonna give one
information or whatever right Garrett
have said no no no there's absolutely no
reason for this and that's one of the
film things that the film tries to
demonstrate so when you see it you
anyone who encounters it the first time
senses it as something just
overwhelmingly sort of overstuffed in a
certain sense right it really hits you
hard okay that's one thing that he was
trying to do um the other thing is that
he in this film is that he was there's a
kind of anti illusionism in there too so
one of the he he was someone who rightly
or wrongly felt that the traditional
vocation of art to create beautiful or
pleasing illusions was questionable so
one of the things that he continually
does in the film is to break the
illusion now of course you you can't get
rid of illusion in film it's impossible
film is just images it is just you know
gets you know images projected on the
screen so what he does continually is he
shows he'll show an image he'll show the
key what the cameraman did to get the
image then he'll show what the editor
did or is doing in order to put the
images together so at a certain point of
the film it's like you're watching at
least three films at once the film as
it's sort of happening in front of you
the film is it's shot and the film is
it's being put to get
which makes it an unusually complex
experience but at the same time I guess
what's what's really kind of miraculous
about it is that he does this with just
extraordinary grace and deafness it is
again from a sensory point of view it
happens very fast and quickens on but
there's a kind of at the same time he
manages a kind of clarity that you
wouldn't think would be possible
actually and that's I think that's one
of the reasons why people admire the
film so much okay and what about some of
his other films
well his other film he was actually
involved I mean most of most of his
films were let's call them agitation or
propaganda films that were done on order
okay and he took those orders okay from
from for instance he wrote it he put
together a film for the Moscow City
Council when they were getting when they
were having elections called stride
Soviet that was actually a kind of
propaganda film about their the
achievements of the City Council but he
used these a film like that to conduct
all kinds of experiments so for instance
in that film you never see any of the
members of the City Council instead of a
meeting of the council or a meeting of
people before the council and so on he
has a meeting of cars and like cars and
machines talking to each other it's an
extremely eccentric kind of a decision
right he has he inserts experiments and
editing into films like this right
needless to say the Moscow City Council
was not totally happy with this so that
was that was one of the things that he
did so and yet at the same time he did
take them seriously as in terms of the
assignment that he was given right he
was very very interested in sound before
he was interested in filmmaking he was
interested in sound he was a very
skilled and tutored musician he studied
at the Bialystok conservatory he studied
at a military musical Institute during
the First World War and he was very
interested apparently even before the
Revolution in
using non musical sound in an artistic
way look say so
organizing he was interested in the for
instance the sound of sawmills okay so
in a film when Chris sound starts to
come in nineteen twenty seven twenty
eight in the world of cinema it doesn't
come in until about twenty nine thirty
in the Soviet Union he makes the first
sound film in Ukraine actually he made
three of his probably his three greatest
films in Ukraine and so he made a film
called enthusiasm in nineteen thirty
that actually integrates industrial
noise in a musical way so he would
record it and then organize it in such a
way that he that it created these
musical patterns this film also created
a scandal for this reason but it's now
seen as the predecessor of all kinds of
later noise experiments in music why was
it a scandal well because it was thought
to be unbelievably noisy and cacophonous
and so forth right and that nobody would
like it and workers wouldn't like it and
so forth it's difficult part of the
reason for the scandal might also have
been sound reproduction capacity there
so we don't quite I mean he was really I
mean way ahead of his time in terms of
what he was trying to do with the film
and it's not clear that the that the you
know sound capacity of the theaters that
he was that he was dealing with like the
amplifiers and so on could really handle
it so that's another question it's a
little bit it's a little bit uncertain
right yeah it meant with a better
response in the West actually so you
know as I'm sitting here listening to
you you had mentioned that he was very
much into poetry at one point and then
you state how he was almost militantly
against any kind of fiction or allusion
in his movies and to me that kind of
contradicts him being a poet
did he grapple with that at all well
you've identified one of the many
contradictions sort of characterized his
work this is very good
he the kind of poetry that he was
particularly interested in is this is
rather difficult to convey the sense of
it in English he was very interested in
some of the poetry of the Russian
futurists and the poetry in particular
that he seemed to really like was a kind
of poetry that even though it had a kind
of sense there was a kind of meaning you
when you read it it was almost as like
as though the meaning was sort of
emerging out of the sounds of the of the
letters themselves rather than using
sound in order to convey some sort of
meaning the letters the material of the
letters came first and and certainly in
such a way that it didn't it felt almost
more like the sounds were expressing
themselves rather than a poet for
instance okay and that this this is at
least his way of thinking about this
particular kind of poetry in other words
it's a kind it was a kind of poetry that
also got rid of a lot of the standard
tropes cliches conventions of poetry of
lyric poetry right that really treated
language as a kind of raw material
independently of pre-existing literary
convention it's really that sort of
extraction of convention or ejection of
convention from art that was was really
central to his work let's jump to the
last twenty years of his life you
mentioned that he virtually did not
produce anything what was going on well
it's a complicated story I mean he there
were a number of things um after he made
his last major film three songs of Lenin
in 1934 which was a major success during
the course of that film he got ill and
it's not quite clear what the illness
was but his health started to fail him
clearly at this point and that seems to
have been one of the
another thing is that in the Soviet
Union I mean like in other places too it
was important to have patrons
okay now patronage relationships are
important in any society in my view I've
noticed them even here right but in the
Soviet Union it was crucial and viata
limited the number of patrons he could
get in part by alienating a lot of
people in the 1920s with his militant
attacks on fiction film that clearly
even though I mean you know one could
question how serious they were they they
were taken seriously by a lot of people
in the film industry and he did you know
upset a lot of people so that was one
thing and he was never a part of the
film education institutions that started
to exist already in the 1920s which were
huge okay if you with one thought within
the film school the main film schools
that was a sort of instant way that you
could create a kind of a body of people
around yourself right then in the in the
1930s the end of the 1930s of course
there was the Great Terror and a number
of people who had in fact helped him
along the way including the
aforementioned Mikhail Koltsov his
famous journalists were killed in the
terror yeah at the in his case right at
the end of it very late in 1939 okay so
that again sort of wipes out a possible
source of support right of push within
the industry because you really needed
that okay so those are a couple of the
factors and then bad luck too there was
a major project that was about to get
off the ground right at the beginning of
1941 but you know what happened in June
1941 and so that was that ended and then
in during the war he was they were
evacuated to Kazakhstan where much of
the film industry was he did make a
couple films they're actually quite
interesting in their own way
but he wasn't able to work as freely as
he wanted to and then over the during
the war he
at the end of the war that his entire
family the ones who stayed in Bialystok
had all been killed by the Nazis so the
whole there all of them and this seemed
to have a major effect on his work
I should mention somebody I have not
mentioned yet which is his wife Eunice
have you got the Smeal of who he got
together with at the beginning of the
1920s her career
they basically works on all their films
together they're like a like a dyad
effectively and it's interesting in
light of what I just said about the
artifice family that she's the one who
edited the very first film about
Auschwitz the very first photo Schwinns
and was also the co-director of the
first major film a giant film about the
Nuremberg trials okay so these were we
know also from correspondents that
Vieira took an interest in the fate of
his family of course and all the rest of
it and it does seem as though this kind
of cast a shadow over him and then the
final blow was really delivered in 1949
when after the establishment the State
of Israel initially you know that the
Soviet Union was on the side of his was
with Israel and then there was of course
this major split that occurred and this
was accompanied in by in within the
Soviet Union on a kind of campaign
against Jewish intellectuals okay he got
caught up in the middle of this and was
publicly attacked by the deputy minister
of cinematography and he went on stage
and was going to himself denounce his
formalist experiment man with the movie
camera but he had a breakdown and he
couldn't deliver the speech and he was
carried off and essentially he fell into
silence after that he worked
occasionally on newsreels and so forth
right but basically that was it and -
and he died of stomach cancer in 1954 so
well after all of that do you think his
work in had an influence on other
filmmakers it did I mean we know that it
had an influence within the Soviet Union
the in various ways sometimes an
influence that was even denied certainly
in the 1920s one can see there were
certain people that he worked with who
continued to make films the documentary
films whether they're really in the in
the spirit of Xia Vieira is another
question there were a few people who got
to know about his work during his trips
abroad he made two trips abroad to
Europe and they also kind of kept the
flame alive but the truth is that his
films were essentially unknown or an
unwatched between about 1935 and about
1955 with a couple very rare exceptions
okay
so 20 years which is which are 20 of the
most important years in film history
really he's unknown you start to get a
revival a small revival at the end of
the 1950's beginning of the 60s starting
in the Soviet Union but then as prints
start to become available
he becomes a very very important figure
starting at the end of the 1960s in the
beginning of the 1970s when various
kinds of radical filmmakers in the
United States and Europe and so forth
interested in either politically or
formally radical filmmaking look to his
work as a kind of model okay so for
instance the famous jean-luc Gouda one
of the most famous French filmmakers in
his in his most politically radical
phase he set up a group actually just
him and another guy called the Dziga
Vertov group okay named after him right
whether or not they made films in the
arts of spirit is another question right
but his radical stance these are the the
existing cinema was something that they
took as inspirational and then later
starting again in the night early 1970s
with the emergence of a cadet
film studies in in university curricula
you start to get essays being written
mostly about man with a movie camera
some sometimes about his life as well
and those and VHS tapes started to
appear and all the rest of it and
gradually gradually he starts to become
canonized as part of the film studies
curriculum in around 1983 a major
addition of his writings appears in
English it had appeared in 1966 and in
in Russia and so by now by this time
effectively at least within Film Studies
again I'd say man with a movie camera is
probably the most studied of all Soviet
films in just generally even more than
Eisenstein's battleship potemkin or
anything like that and many many
filmmakers now speak of him as an
influence and it's so it's interesting
so it's a he's a pioneer of film in some
ways but his real effect is belated
right right well this has been
fascinating right thanks for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work oh you're very welcome darling
thanks for more information about
Professor McKay and his research please
visit our website at macmillan report
led you be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale
you